[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
eeuu volvió a batir su propio récord en
cuanto al número de emigrantes que
entran al país según la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza durante
abril se registraron las cifras más
altas de los últimos 20 años más de 178
mil personas llegaron de manera
irregular lo que supone un 3% más que en
marzo sin embargo disminuyó la llegada
de menores no acompañados uno de los
principales cruces de entrada para los
migrantes procedentes de centroamérica
es el río grande
mamen sala desde la zona de frontera no
se explica la situación que enfrentan
los que deciden cruzar el río en balsas
poco seguras
en lo que llevamos de 2021 ha seguido
aumentando la llegada de migrantes
indocumentados a eeuu sobre todo cada
vez son más niños los motivos son varios
la violencia los desastres naturales la
inseguridad alimentaria y económica y
esa crisis provocada por la pandemia
aquí en texas uno de los puntos más
activos por los que entran estos
migrantes indocumentados es precisamente
esto que están viendo río grande que
separa méxico de eeuu y aunque la
distancia es muy cortita atravesar este
río es muy peligroso porque las
corrientes son muy fuertes y la persona
que lo cruza se juega la vida sobre todo
en esas barcas que utilizan los coyotes
estos hombres que se encargan de
transportar a las personas de una orilla
a otra porque son barcas con muy poca
seguridad sin salvavidas y en muchos
casos en ellas hay hasta 16 personas muy
inseguro pero los migrantes
indocumentados muchas veces no solo
piensan dos veces porque la situación en
sus países de origen es todavía peor y
por eso deciden jugarse en la vida y de
eso precisamente se aprovechan los
coyotes muchas veces tratan de
carlos de convencerlos diciéndoles que
con la administración de biden es mucho
más fácil entrar en el país algo que se
aleja mucho de la realidad
ha sido un largo viaje pero por fin pisa
en suelo estadounidense
tres madres con sus cuatro hijos
pequeños más dos menores de 17 años que
viajan solos al frente de la frágil
barca hinchable está este hombre el
coyote miembro de una mafia que cobra
hasta 12 mil dólares a cada pasajero por
cruzar las peligrosas aguas del río
grande desde que vienes huyendo de la
delincuencia mucha violencia en el país
algunos hace más de dos meses que
salieron de su casa como maría hilda
viaja con sus dos hijos de 7 y 10 años
mejor que es lo que te gustaría ver en
eeuu
para poder alcanzar su sueño nada más
llegar se entregan a la patrulla
fronteriza ellos decidirán si se inicia
un proceso de asilo o son devueltos a su
país de origen los que consiguen
quedarse en eeuu para seguir su proceso
se refugian aquí unas horas en el
albergue de la hermana norma
llegan cerca de 300 personas cada día la
mayoría todos han cruzado el río la
patrulla fronteriza nos ha procesado y
se encuentran ahora aquí con nosotros
porque van en camino hacia dónde está su
familia en eeuu como esta familia
venezolana que lo perdió todo durante su
viaje toda la mochila los documentos la
ropa todo lo perdimos como estas
[Música]
fue el trayecto
mente somos valientes
[Música]
al día siguiente llega el golpe de
suerte diana y su familia han conseguido
unos billetes para viajar a florida y
reunirse con los suyos ahora habrá que
esperar 60 días a que un juez decida si
se les otorga o no el tan ansiado y
esperado asilo
en el tránsito los traficantes o coyotes
se encargan de llevar a los migrantes al
otro lado de la frontera por vías
inseguras pero las cosas están cambiando
con la administración baiden amén sala
nos explica
a medida que se levantan las
restricciones por la pandemia del cob y
19 y se descongela el sistema migratorio
de estados unidos- la administración de
haydn sigue lanzando una serie de
medidas para acabar con el tráfico de
personas que llegan a eeuu una de estas
últimas medidas es precisamente la
llamada operación centinela se trata de
una operación en la que trabajan
conjuntamente la dea el fbi y otras
agencias gubernamentales el principal
objetivo es acabar con el tráfico ilegal
de personas que llegan aquí en eeuu
poner fin a esas organizaciones
trasnacionales así que a partir de ahora
se va a perseguir también a los coyotes
esas personas que transportan a los
migrantes de un lado a otro de la
frontera se les va a identificar y se
les va a sancionar como pues se les van
a revocar sus visados y se les van a
congelar las cuentas económicas que
puedan tener en eeuu además de cualquier
actividad comercial que puedan poseer en
el país se trata de asegurar al máximo
la frontera y de proteger a los
migrantes más
sobre todo a los niños que cada vez son
más los que llegan aquí en unas
condiciones realmente peligrosas para
que se hagan una idea solo en el 2020
250 niños fallecieron tratando de cruzar
la frontera funcionarios del gobierno de
aseguran que abril es el primer mes de
la nueva administración en el que los
cruces no tuvieron un aumento
considerable y reconocen que se logró
gracias al despliegue de hasta 10.000
uniformados mexicanos a lo largo de la
frontera con guatemala hasta que
inmigrantes de france 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]